foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
check check check one two one two one
two one two
um people of the internet
man my chair is so loud
I've heard it before on stream it does
not come across as loud on stream
thankfully
as it does on my end but it's still
pretty loud
welcome in welcome in welcome in
hey Dustin with the five gifted
with the five gifted to get us started
Dustin thank you so much dude appreciate
it
Jamal Skye Izzy moonlace and Northwoods
Nomad all gifted a membership there
thank you so much Dustin appreciate that
my friend and Elwyn with the five gifted
as well
goodness it's like coming home you guys
we took a week off of the YouTube lives
last week
because we did
um a four hour stream the week before
Elwyn with the five gift as well let's
see who got those who got those from L
one
see Samantha Brittany scalinity Anna and
Stefan
congratulations folks congratulations I
know right Claude Roth
so generous
yes our first stream of the week man we
uh
had to do some odds and ends today have
to get the driver's license
renewed and updated it was time for that
so I didn't have time to squeeze in a
stream for gameplay
but man I'm itching to get back into uh
Star Wars to be honest with you guys
I thought about I thought about maybe
doing a Star Wars stream immediately
after our YouTube live tonight but I
just I have to be up too early tomorrow
I just can't welcome to Griffin I just
can't
but Elwyn thank you so much for the
gifteds guys if you got one of those
gifted Subs
enjoy your emotes
special Discord roll
have to remind myself okay we're on
YouTube now it's not ad-free viewing
when you get a membership here well
well Cloud Roth with the two months
elwyn's got the gold the six months
let's go wait somebody else was saying
they had gold too
look at all the golds I think Dr sherbet
is about to have a gold Maybe
elwyn's gold indeed
Samantha welcome in welcome in Paula
how's it going they have already Paula
already
there you go six months for Dr sherbet
nice
still have one month to go for gold
Jenny hey almost there
almost there
no but I thought we could uh I thought
we could use tonight to kind of test out
a new format I was playing around with
like a new thumbnail today too I want to
get like a thumbnail set
that can just be like the standard retro
rack into her live like for this weekly
live stream
and so what I was thinking was
I had like
I see it would vary from week to week
but I want this to turn into kind of a
almost like a gaming podcast
but podcasts with one person is hard
thing to do so
on days like today when you have three
trailers from three epic game franchises
that I haven't I actually haven't
watched any of these trailers yet
it works out perfectly it'll be perfect
but you don't always have that so
but yeah I was thinking so we would do
like
maybe like five gaming stories each week
like where we just we just like hit the
news like this is the latest
that's happening in gaming and or
anything Hogwarts Legacy related we
would cover there too like today we got
the announcement of
the Legacy live being tomorrow actually
instead of on Friday
so like little things like that
happening in The Wizarding World
happening in video games maybe even
touch on movies or books if it's like
you know something really big and just
have like five stories that we just boom
boom boom boom boom like hit them really
quick
and then have like a topic of the week
which is where we would spend like the
bulk of our time
and then I was thinking for the last
part it would be like
chat q a hangout
just really what it a lot of the a lot
of it turns into anyway but yeah I want
to get some like little segments and
things to break it up
you think it's a great idea Cloud Roth
Destiny you got a month left for gold
we're criminals got a live stream Final
Fantasy when it comes out okay here's
showing you how how little I know about
this when does it even come out
maybe it maybe it's gonna say in the
trailer I have no idea
but yeah man it's like
I I don't know how this happened but
when I went full time I'm like oh dude
we're gonna have so much time
to to do uh streams to make videos to do
our YouTube live interacting with the
community to do more Discord posts and
social media
and it's like I now I'm like how did I
ever do it before how did I do how did I
keep up with all the Hogwarts Legacy
stuff before I have no idea I
because I feel like I have less time now
which makes zero sense
it makes zero sense however I will say
one thing that I've I'm really working
on improving is my sleep so that that
could be why
because man I'm telling you guys when it
when I was working full time and then I
would get home and I'm like well
Hogwarts likes the news dropped videos
got to be made I would just stay up I
would just stay up
stay up until as long as it took now I'm
trying to get in bed at a decent hour
but it's just like I'm trying to do two
videos a week
and it's like I mean it took me all day
all day yesterday wait what is today
today's Tuesday right yeah Monday was an
editing day like I was editing pretty
much the entire day
pretty much the entire day was was spent
editing
or consider a podcast get some mods in a
call or maybe some channelmen oh if we
had like yeah see I was thinking about
that's another thing Skye it like maybe
the topic of the week
okay this is this is really rambling
here to start but just just to since you
brought it up one podcast that I've
always wanted to start I may have
mentioned this before it's called the
Retro wrecking tour show it's like a
one-on-one video game interview Series
where I interview other it would
probably start out with other content
creators but it could just be anybody
like you said it could be mods it could
just be people from the community just
just people that I meet people that I
know that that are gamers
and instead of like focusing on current
gaming stuff focus on like
not even not even like their favorite
game of all time
but
what is like some of their their best
gaming memories growing up
especially people who who grew up if
you're around my age who remember what
it was like before the internet
to where you know you couldn't just run
home or pull out your phone and figure
out how to solve something yeah you
could have strategy guide and
stuff like that but it was like all
these little like playground
conversations
so yeah that's like one idea that's
simmering but I don't know that it would
fit on this channel
so I don't know I don't know but yeah
even if I kept it the structure that I
just described to you guys like a gaming
new show
if we had like a rotating guest each
week
but that'd be hard to keep up like to
have a guest every week it's like I've
got I've got quite a few Creator friends
but after about I don't know two months
they might be sick of it by that point
you remember that Rin
Mrs raconteur in the house as well yeah
there was there was a severe lack of
sleep I've been doing better
on that for sure
yeah Dustin the interview podcast is
like my long term
that's in like the long range Vision
almost feel like that would have to be a
whole separate Channel although YouTube
is really pushing podcasts right now and
they have this feature where
you can like make podcasts their own
separate playlist but here's another
thing about podcasting
I almost like them better when there's
not
chat interaction
if that makes sense like live streams
are great because you get that immediate
feedback but like a true podcast it's
just like that just one person and the
other person maybe you know a handful of
people I usually feel like podcasts are
best like if you get more than like four
I feel like four is kind of like the max
for a really good podcast but two to
three is is just I feel like that's
perfect
because like chat and a live stream I
think it's better suited to other types
of content but like for that deep dive
podcast
I feel like it might be better for uh
for to not do it live
but yeah anyway like those are all some
of the ideas
bouncing around in my head right now but
I feel like that one is is to uh I feel
like that would be more long term the
Retro the Retro wrecking tour show but
I've I've pitched that to several
friends for years and I
like I know even if I can't explain it
well like I know the types of
conversations I can hear them because
one of my buddies at work he and I used
to just
it's like I could I could throw out a
topic for him I could throw out a game
for him
and because of the era he grew up in
he could just like launch into like
three or four different stories she just
about that
and I'm like dude we need to do a
podcast for this and then the more I
thought about it I'm like you know what
everybody has stories like that
everybody has stories not necessarily
the best game you ever played but some
of the best stories
that happened in your life like that
that's unique to you and that's what's
so awesome about games you know it's
like you remember where you were at when
you first played that game if it was
multiplayer like you remember the people
you played it with
that sort of thing
but yeah I definitely want to do the new
like this news Style Show so we'll see
how it goes tonight I've got like a few
topics I don't have a full five and I
don't have a topic I do not have a topic
of the week but
Ragnar welcome in welcome in
yeah dude I enjoy I enjoy first person
games yeah
cheers of the Kingdom hype is at an
all-time high I haven't seen it yet
we're about to watch it together
about to watch it together welcome in
Moon Lily Alexis
people of the internet
oh Rin I got an order in on the Pro
Controller
yeah I I wasn't um
I wasn't interested in the switch itself
because I actually just got an OLED
switch for for like um doing my Let's
Plays and such
and I prefer kind of just the simple
simple look of the white OLED
but um but I did get get an order in for
the controller Best Buy is where I got
mine in
but yeah Dustin like a once a month
thing I almost think I would want to
like pre-record a bunch of them
like batch them and then release them
weekly on like a new channel or
something but we got to get the fur we
gotta get we gotta focus on our main
Channel build up the let's play Channel
if you guys are here and you haven't
followed the let's play Channel yet we
do
have a dedicated let's play Channel now
retro raconteur let's plays
youtube.com slash and then you can just
do the little at actually here I'll just
post it in the chat for you guys because
I don't think
I don't think I made a command for it
here yet
I have a command for twitch but I don't
think I have one for here
there you go there it is yeah so we've
been doing uh as you mentioned Cloud
Roth we've been doing Metroid Prime
Let's Plays over there we just started
posting our Hogwarts Legacy Let's Plays
over there now
and we're getting ready to post
actually I think did I set that to go
live tomorrow I think I did tomorrow our
first Star Wars uh Jedi Fallen order
let's play will go up you've already
seen it on Twitch then you know what to
expect but if you haven't
stay tuned tomorrow
more gameplays you think so yeah yeah
that's why we got the uh that's what the
let's play channel is for yep
you just subscribe bourbon nice thank
you very much
appreciate it
new dog how's it going been a while
since you caught a stream back before
Hogwarts Legacy well welcome back man
glad you stopped by again we're still uh
still doing the live streaming been
streaming a lot more on Twitch recently
doing some gameplay stuff over there but
we were kind of just sitting here
talking about the future of this
live show
and you know I mean maybe the live the
I call it the live show I guess twitch
is live too but this this could
eventually move over to Twitch too if we
wanted it to or the gameplay could
eventually move over here
it's all like up in the air it's all
about what you guys what works and what
you guys enjoy
because the plan was originally all the
gameplay was gonna be YouTube I was
going to do all the live streaming on
YouTube and then Avalanche started doing
the uh the twitch drops
and so I started doing some twitch
streams to so we could could help out
with the drops and then that just kind
of took off and it's been going well
over there so
yes my first playthrough Timothy my
first playthrough we've been streaming
it live on Twitch I've never
surprisingly am relatively like blind on
a lot of the stuff in there
story I don't know much about the um
hey the word doctor thank you for
subscribing yeah I don't know a lot
about the gameplay other than people
said it's like similar to souls but I've
played probably
we've done two like three three hour
streams
so give or take you know a little bit
for talking here and there five five and
a half hours of gameplay so far
the first one I actually had to split
even sooner than I was thinking because
I had I had like three solid hours of
good gameplay but for Let's Plays I
don't really like it going over two
hours so I try to keep it like an hour
and hour and a half to two hours in that
range
or I mean less is great too but
so yeah that'll be hitting tomorrow on
the let's play Channel
you only switch when you hear about yeah
something special going on
yeah twitch is really good for uh like
the chat
the chat interaction and all of that is
great
that's right Paulie yeah that was at the
end of the Star Wars stream I think
oh that's right I bet I have a lot of
stuff I could cut off the end for the
let's play you know
you'll watch a four hour YouTube video
of the story can't get into the oh like
the back tracking
ah see I haven't gotten to any of that
yet so
Star Wars Eclipse no I haven't seen the
trailer for that should we add that one
to our list to watch tonight
yeah welcome in guys welcome in get
comfortable
we're gonna be checking out some of the
latest gaming trailers here so thank you
guys so much for being here stopping by
Star Wars Eclipse no I haven't even
heard of this
oh it's a cinematic trailer
is it for Jedi Survivor or is it
something different
Star Wars eclipse
oh my gosh this was over a year ago it
has 18 million views
I've not heard about this
at all
it's by Quantic dream
what
see this is like I went in a hole for
two and a half years of work family and
Hogwarts Legacy
and and YouTube like if you count that
work family Hogwarts Legacy slash
YouTube
and so I'm slowly like getting to come
out of that Hogwarts Legacy part now
and see a little bit of uh
what else is happening in the world of
games
it's darker I mean if it's made by
Quantic dream
I'm not even I'm not even gonna ask any
more questions I'm gonna we're gonna
watch that trailer too we'll add that to
the list it's a really old one but who
cares
no Cloud Roth hopefully this week
I've been checking around on pricing
which I will not reveal to you guys what
we've found on the pricing but uh it's
been more expensive everywhere actually
my my sister found like a smaller post
office close to where she lives
it cracks me up we're gonna get this PO
Box you guys are gonna send like a bunch
of things at the beginning and then it's
just gonna sit there for like five
months
but it will be good to have it will be
good to have like that professional
address but yeah I'm hoping to finally
make a decision by the end of the week
set a good while before TPM
The Phantom Menace oh wow
all right guys well let's go ahead and
shift over here
shift things over to the commentary View
what I call this one and hold on let me
check my
make sure our
just ignore that for a second
there we go
a lot of Star Wars games coming out
more besides those two
all right so our first news item to
discuss
tonight ladies and gentlemen we have
an update from Hogwarts Legacy
the Hogwarts Clock Tower is chiming the
next Legacy live from Avalanche software
is tomorrow March 29th at 9 00 a.m
Pacific time
and this is their let's see they're
doing it every other week
a live stream where Chandler it was last
time it was Chandler and Andrew are just
kind of going through with their
playthrough of the game so I assume
they're going to be picking up where
they left off
and they did like what three four hours
laughs last time somewhere in there
and they drop you know they drop a few
tidbits here and there about
some interesting things we did find a
new Easter egg last time
thanks to them live streaming
so if you guys haven't seen
uh we posted a video Let's see last week
our video on 10 secrets in Hogwarts
Legacy
I'll show you here
well when Deputy had mistress Matilda
Weasley this one right here
and so
let's see I think it's secret number two
no it's secret number
five right here
so they showed us this right here
this vase
and it has two bottles of butter beer in
it
we found this out through their stream
last week now you can't actually you
can't really tell on this video
oh wait right there maybe
it definitely says butter beer though
some people were saying
that's not butter beer
I may not show it all that great in the
video but it definitely
oh you can't tell from that angle right
there
oh wait maybe I keep maybe hold on oh
never mind I don't show it all the way
but yeah it is it is a butter beer two
butter beer bottles
which people reminded me there could
actually I guess be two references so I
thought it was probably a reference to
Dobby
and him taking care of Winky
and her getting addicted
to butter beer basically is what I
thought it was reference to but a lot of
people in the comments pointed out there
was also professor chalani
who drank a lot of Sherry and would hide
her bottles in the room of requirement I
don't think it ever said a vase
but I'm like hey that could actually it
could actually work for both of those
things I think it could work for either
one
hahaha
so it's a lot to
I feel like it's probably more for
people who
actually I don't really know who it's
for who do you guys think those live
streams are for
because clearly people that have already
played the game I mean you might be
interested to see if there are any more
secrets
but people that haven't played the game
yet
I'm like would they really want to see
how much they want to see you know
or winky I know right
Dobby just
oh you gotta love Dobby taking care of
her
I love looking at these little graphs on
YouTube like it shows you what people
were most interested in
so you see these this little like wave
down here so there's a lot at the
beginning and then it drops off and then
we get a little bit of a bump right here
at secret one
secret two secret four let's see what
was this one
people were really interested in this
one oh this was the uh at the the lake
something oddly solemn about this place
such Regal creatures
yeah the reference to the Patronus the
Stag and then this one
so fascinating
I mean anytime you put chapter markers
like this you know people are going to
jump around on a list video they're
going to jump to where the next one is
yeah so then you get kind of the drop
down and a little bit of a bump here and
then toward the end
okay starting right here
see this is what is what cracks me about
YouTube man I made a separate video just
on this right here
just on this right here the werewolf one
Tony man this shows you how like
watch this so if I take you guys to my
channel our main Channel page here
so 10 Secrets we're at almost 170 000
views
this right here this Hogwarts Legacy
secret is insane was just a video about
that specific werewolf tapestry 3.5 3
500 views
so like
the thumbnail is probably better and
there's 10 so 10 is better than one
but it's also funny to see that clearly
looking at this right here there were
still a lot of people who uh
hadn't seen that yet
because there's a lot of people
watching this part right here
the look of the algorithm right see I
knew man I'd seen so many people talk
about this secret right here and how
some people even knew about the room but
they didn't know the lumos trick
and so I made that first video the
dedicated one like I know more people
need to know this
and then it didn't perform and I'm just
like okay I'm putting it in this video
too because I I know
I know
I've still seen people
um
like people on Twitter are posting about
stuff that I I'm like I put that in my
tip video
from a month ago
but I get a lot of people probably
didn't watch them because they don't
want to be spoiled they didn't want to
be spoiled
like uh Joe I don't know if Joe Max here
in the chat calling you out Joe
it's all in good fun love you Joe love
you Joe was talking about uh on Twitter
he didn't see that or he didn't know
that with Wingardium Leviosa you can use
the d-pad
to like rotate the object
it's like Joe
it tells you that when you learn the
spell it pops up because I just did that
again in our evil playthrough as uh Lord
retro Mort I just did that again with
with uh pretty sure that one's garlic
yeah that's Professor garlic who teaches
you Wingardium Leviosa and it pops up on
the screen
and Joe's like yeah I've done three
playthroughs I missed it every time
too funny man
you found it by accident Moonlight oh
it's such a cool it's one of my favorite
secrets in the game
and the the fact that you have to use
lumos to like fully reveal it
it's even better
all right so we did have a small that
small bit of Hogwarts Legacy news
right here so if you're interested in
that it'll be tomorrow at 9 00 a.m
Pacific time 12 p.m eastern time I will
say guys I'm getting I'm getting really
worried about my the trophy that I'm
missing for my 100 percent
at first I was not concerned at all like
I was like oh this is gonna be because I
knew it was already on their radar
because it was in
it was in another patch like they had
mentioned that was an issue and they
thought they had fixed it so I'm like
okay this is going to be at the top of
the list this is for sure getting taken
care of
man we haven't heard anything about it
anything
I really do not want to have to I mean I
know it'll get fixed eventually
it's just a matter of how long
all right P the Platinum I know you're
the worst for not reading those Owen I
mean apparently you're not alone
You Are Not Alone
Miranda had one too
I'll call Miranda out too sorry Miranda
I love you angel it's all good it's all
good
what was it she said
oh she says thanks you too I was today
oh actually owing the the loot bags
and Judge Joe also replied to that one
saying I didn't know that
like guys
here's a Shameless plug for my tip video
where you can uh you can accio the loot
bags if you guys didn't know you can
actually have the loot bags in Hogwarts
Legacy
yep yep yep
foreign
first when they didn't have drops
enabled well the first one without drops
was last well they didn't do one last
week but the week before that they did
not they didn't have drops on that one
either
oh yeah the Kotor remake was in a bit of
trouble right
or it changed developers or something
yeah Moonlight I don't blame you if
you're on PS well I guess I don't know
if it's an Xbox issue as well I don't
know
all right trailer time
actually this is what this is a 13
minute
oh man Nintendo is notorious for
I hope we're good on music in this
because I'm gonna watch it here well
anybody on the replay Squad if you see
this later and it just randomly jumps
ahead you'll know why because I had to
go back and edit it out
happened to me before with the uh when
James and I co-stream the game awards
remember they showed a trailer for the
Mario movie
everything in that entire three and a
half hour game awards was completely
fine for copyright except you guessed it
the Mario movie but I actually think it
might have been uh it might have been
the movie studio instead all right I'm
pretty pumped for this guys so Legend of
Zelda tears of the Kingdom gameplay
demonstration you gotta love Nintendo
dude they just
they're they're always just coming out
of nowhere
they're like oh
Zelda gameplay here you go
just out of nowhere
they don't they don't like let the hype
they let the hype build up but they
don't you know they don't play into it
it's like when when they're ready to
announce that's when they announce it
it's usually happening within a couple
days or a week
so here we go
wasn't even a full trailer oh the Mario
one I think it was a pretty short one
yeah
hello everyone
hello
producer of The Legend of Zelda series
don't forget to like the video that's
right Brittany
development on the Legend of Zelda tears
of the kingdom is now complete
wow very much for waiting
what is it may many of you are looking
forward to this game and we've released
a few trailers so far
although it'll just be a brief Glimpse
I'm going to actually play the game for
you all today and show you what it's
like
okay
can I just say real quick I'm so sad
that there's not like a switch to that
this is releasing on
I love Nintendo dude I love them they
will always have a special place in my
heart but guys the switch is so is so
dated man it's so dated like Zelda
imagine Zelda running on a PS5 or an
Xbox series or a PC
oh my goodness the silky smooth frame
rate with I actually love this the
visual style of breath of the wild the
art the artistic style is great but man
that frame rate it's rough okay I
digress I'm still excited for the game
let's begin don't hate me
here we are in the land of Hyrule
like see you look at that end of Zelda
breath of the wild there's a vast world
to explore imagine just like that art
style
but in 4k
running at 60 FPS can I imagine that for
a bit it's not just the system
it's changed in many ways
if she is calling it changes today yeah
yeah time so May 12th okay not for
yourself when the game launches
I mean so the vast world of Hyrule we're
gonna say clearly it looks it looks just
like the first one which is not a bad
thing the landmass is floating up there
we call them Sky Islands
you're probably wondering how do you get
to the sky islands when they're so high
up
some like Skyward Sword if we take Vibes
there oh something's falling from the
sky
look at that little green thing over
there too I wonder what that is let's
head over to it
we're almost at the spot where the
object fell
the climbing mechanic
amazing here it is amazing let's use one
of Link's new abilities
if you do this on the rock that just
fell
rewind
look it started Rising
this power is known as recall which
rewinds an object's movement man that
chica slate it can just do whatever they
want it to do right I can now rise into
the sky we're a lot closer to the sky
islands
let's use the paraglider to reach one of
them
paraglider yes a few other Sky Islands
floating here too
okay so I wonder if that's the only way
you have to like wait for these Falling
Rocks and then use that ability every
time
I made it
surely there'll be other ways right
there are lots of ways to reach the sky
islands so we hope you'll try a few
different methods there we go
it's like they read my mind there are
lots of ways let's listen to that again
there are lots of ways to reach the sky
islands so we hope you'll try a few
different methods can we ride that
Dragon I just it's all over there
because that'd be pretty epic slightly
bigger Sky Island
just like on the surface there are
several man-made structures
some trees are also growing here
you won't see many of those yellow trees
on the surface though
won't see yellow trees on the surface
okay
yeah like the fact that he said lots of
ways when you find something like this
you should pick it up it might come in
handy later
let's continue
a tree branch
oh something's there this is a brand new
enemy called a construct we'll fight it
using the branch we just picked up oh
yikes
ah the branch broke not good not good
quick okay wait so is that do people
already know that that um what's it
called the weapon degradation
I guess that's back I mean most people
probably assume that it that it would be
all looks very very similar to the to
the first game
expected fighting with just a branch
won't get us very far
also this branch is almost broken so
here's another one of Link's new
abilities if we use this branch and the
rock over here and do this
look we can stick them together we
created a makeshift Hammer this is
called waves come together
okay so that is also a new Chic ability
so he's got the old wooden Shield okay
so he could have done it with the shield
too and do this
look we can stick them together we
created a makeshift Hammer interesting
you can stick objects okay another quick
interjection here one of the I mean
probably the biggest strength of the
first game if any of you haven't played
it is it just gave you so much freedom
in terms of how you could approach a
situation
and there were many different ways to
accomplish the same task that was one of
the things that the game really
succeeded at and people still I mean
you'll see even even within the past
year people have posted new videos like
new mechanics and new secrets that they
found in breath of the wild which is a
pretty old game at this point
that are mechanics that that just it's
it's crazy like you don't even you
wonder if they even thought of all the
things that are possible so when they
introduce mechanics like this
that's another example of one that's
just gonna have like to create so many
crazy uses let's take on another okay
wait hold on I think he said something
important there to create new weapons
with various effects
okay
six years old yeah
oh we beat one
the weapon's attack has definitely
improved and it didn't break either
but this weapon has much better
durability
I promise I haven't watched this
I guess I'm like their typical viewer
everything I'm asking or commenting on
they're they're addressing shortly
thereafter
do all sorts of things oh you guys talk
about their
yeah the commentary is just a bit a bit
uh a bit dry
what was that again things by
experimenting with the phone
experimenting yeah
yeah you confuse two weapons for example
if we take this long stick and fuse it
with a pitchfork
we can create a weapon attack range
okay that is cool this we don't have to
get too close to enemies and we can
safely attack from a distance I mean
just thinking about all the items that
were in breath of the wild materials in
your inventory for instance try fusing
this Leaf to an arrow
what
fuse an ice Elemental material to an
arrow and
you can freeze far away enemies
so does that replace like the ice arrows
and stuff wait do they not show us what
the leaf does using this Leaf to an
arrow
oh they don't show us what it uses
Elemental material to an arrow and
you can freeze far away enemies
okay so ice is the white one I wonder if
the blue is
water a water arrow
very useful
in addition
let's see
you're gonna have to buy a switch again
if you're out hunting you might feel
that aiming with an arrow is too
difficult
apparently my eyes can't track fast
moving objects as of late so my shots
rarely land
at times like these
lock on here's an eyeball you can get by
defeating monsters
fuse it to an arrow and
looked no way
that is like Nintendo game designers at
their best right there like that's not
even a new item that is something that
was in the first game those eyeballs
I'll just fire in that general direction
oh that is crazy depending on what you
stick together the fusibility could also
be beneficial for hunting
they've talked about hunting a couple
times I used a mushroom to my shield now
you're probably wondering if this and he
was was hunting
was hunting in the first game at all
what do they mean hunting
has any use well this mushroom is
actually a puff shroom
let's fight an enemy with this
I blocked with the shield
okay there's smoke now the enemies lost
sight of links so a stealth attack
even if you struggle with combat you can
take down enemies using similar methods
in the previous game you'd usually get
powerful weapons by defeating strong
enemies but in this game fusing even the
weakest weapon with something else could
turn it into a useful weapon oh my gosh
options for sticking things together let
me demonstrate
okay so what does this mean for master
sword do we know if Master Sword it's
got to be in the game right Sky Islands
even have Rivers because one of my I
don't know if this would be a critique
or not
like the weapon stuff is cool
but eventually I hit a point where
it's like dude I'm link I want to use my
master sword and that's it just like I'm
playing Star Wars right now I want to
use the lightsaber yeah there's a lot of
other cool weapons you could use but at
the end of the day I'm a Jedi I want to
use a lightsaber at the end of the day
I'm link I want to use the master sword
we'll want to cross this one but
swimming across it well the river's too
wide for that we need a boat two right
too wide for swimming of course
stamina around here
so we'll lift up this log and attach it
to a second log
oh my gosh dude let's do one more
we'll bring this over here and attach a
third log
it's like they're bringing in survival
there's another new ability called Ultra
Minecraft almost currently attached they
can be detached let's modify the shape
of the raft
dude that chica slate is op man attached
things or detach them it is op
P you think you could easily swim that
moonly I think what it is is
to swim in this game it's like your
stamina
maybe his stamina is not high enough yet
it'll probably run out before he made it
to the other side put this on the water
it's made of wood so the buoyancy will
keep it afloat
we've made a simplified version of a
boat okay now we need an ore or like a
sail it won't move in its current state
so we'll need something to propel it
forward
that leaf that that uh
there's something here let's try hitting
it
it's got a battery wind it's blowing
wind
how convenient would you look at that
Master Sword has been confirmed in the
Hylian Shield
will attach another one
this should make the boat have a good
one Paula thank you for stopping by
well he's putting two on
okay okay like when guardian Leviosa
guys did you see that you can rotate it
okay you can rotate there
all that is sick
hey it's moving dude that is cool man
from the fans well no what happens with
the battery goes out
since we added two fans we should be
able to cross the river in no time
all right we reached the other side
in the most recent trailer we showed
scenes of Link riding a large car and a
flying machine
those Vehicles actually aren't in the
game from the start instead you'll be
able to freely craft them on your own
there are always wait
a trailer we showed scenes of Link
riding a large car and a flying machine
those Vehicles actually aren't in the
game from the start instead you'll be
able to really craft them on your own
there are all sorts of objects you'll
come across in this game and depending
on how you use your remote dude this is
you can do a lot with them so try
crafting different things it almost
makes me think of like Scribblenauts
anybody ever played Scribblenauts
where you could like type in things but
here you just you have to find them in
the world this building over here okay
watch this
look I passed right through the ceiling
this new ability is called Ascend if
you're in a place with a ceiling you can
go through
to the floor above you oh that's
dude these like all three of these
things these abilities they have shown
are just like
absolute game changers for how you there
are some play this game what's great
about this ability is that as long as
there's a ceiling you can use it
anywhere
for example this place has a cave with a
hill right above it oh my gosh it really
visibility here
I feel so Opie
so you can just instantly get out
we emerged at the top of the hill Oh my
gosh that is totally like it's a bug not
a feature
they took what if you've ever seen games
where people like get stuck in the in
the world like areas are not supposed to
be
they basically took that concept and
made it into a feature link can move
through anything but only only the
ceilings use stamina to climb a mountain
but in this game if there's a mountain
with a cave like this one you can now
get to the top without having to climb
all the way up here's another example
imagine you're stuck in a cage if it's
got a ceiling you know what to do right
exactly
you're stuck in a cage there's another
construct
it seems to be holding a strange weapon
some enemies are equipped with fused
weapons so battles will play out a bit
differently from the previous game
ah it blew me away with wind
looks like it's got some sort of fan
yeah I got pushed off oh we got launched
oh well let's just return to the surface
and still survive though it's all good
you can quickly descend from the sky to
the surface like this
it feels so good
in the sky you'll be able to look out
across the land
you can also search for destinations
that pique your interest
once you've chosen your destination you
can speed things up like this
let's dive into this River
and we're back on the surface
wow
there are still so many things I'd like
to show you but let's leave it at that
for now no is it almost up oh my gosh
that went by so fast
what did you think
okay I still have a big question
I want to know about Dungeons man I want
to know if traditional dungeons are back
let's finish it though and then we'll
Link's new abilities in the previous
game
I'm sure some of you watching me play
were thinking wait if you could do that
then maybe you could do this too
in this game you can do a lot of things
just by thinking about what's even you
can do a lot of things
there's still a lot of new gameplay
Mysteries and encounters we couldn't
show today but they're all jam-packed
into this unfamiliar Hyrule Mysteries
that's all for today thank you for
watching
[Music]
no way
interesting so they focused I mean the
whole thing was was basically focusing
on the three
the three new abilities that they wanted
to Showcase oh yeah and then looks like
they're gonna show off the
let's take a look at the switch
also it does have a design on the back
of the
right there you get like those little
designs
by the way if you guys are ever
interested in a special edition switch
just so you don't make the same mistake
I did they do not include a copy of the
game I know crazy right
so it does not include a copy of the
game
even if you get this one right here
I like the back and I like the I'm not a
huge fan of the joy cons
I like the dot quite a bit
something about the white and the gold I
like a little bit better than the like
the green and the gold
[Music]
damn it like how do they get okay with
that
we'll see there it was there there it
was at the bottom
game and systems sold separately like
like why
just put a digital code in there man
charge 50 bucks more or whatever 60
bucks more
oh
Man Okay Okay Okay so
thoughts everybody what do you guys
think I think a lot of the stuff looks
cool I do like just I can't get over how
oh man like the hardware is just holding
this back so much not in terms of
gameplay you got to give it to Nintendo
man like they're they're gameplay
designers are just top notch
Top Notch and people are going to have
so much fun coming up with new ways to
to just Traverse this world to solve
puzzles encounters I I'll be honest man
like I I really like breath of the wild
I don't want to undersell it I think
it's a fantastic game
but I did miss like the traditional
Zelda dungeons I did I I missed that
aspect of it and then they do have some
side quests but I don't know like like
the shrines and the stuff like that it
just seemed like they really doubled
down on these little um
like mini encounters instead of having
these
these like multi-layered stories which
there are some there are some in in
breath of the wild which
I did the one that had uh probably the
best one it was like it involved this
this city and you had to like get them
the supplies I mean it's been so long
since I played it
so I kind of I kind of miss
I hope that they have something that's a
little bit more like the traditional
dungeons
um because I mean I still like there's
clearly a place for
a style of Zelda game like this where
you can just
go anywhere they want to make you make
it to where you can get there any way
you want to get there
and you have fun with all these
different abilities and all these
different enemy encounters that that's
actually an underrated part of that
presentation right there I think that
little enemy encounter they showed and
how it said sometimes the enemies will
have fused weapons
I mean that could open up a lot of
gameplay possibilities right there but
yeah I do still hope they have some of
the traditional
style dungeons in this one
looks like it'd be fun coming up with
crazy item combos I yeah like that's
totally that's a totally new thing right
there
that wasn't in the first game at all
like the whole fusing of weapons
Timothy I don't care about Graphics 720
TB can't tell a difference but just like
even the frame rate man
this this will probably look so much
better on handheld than like I'm looking
at it right now on a 27 inch monitor it
actually even looks better on my second
monitor where it's size now I'm seeing
what you guys are seeing
when it's not like blowing taking up the
full screen
but yeah if it could just like if it ran
at a better frame rate and was at a
higher resolution
oh but the gameplay looks great it looks
great I'm curious to see
because they said that was what they
showed three new abilities all with the
Chica slate and also I wonder what's
going on in the top left right there
see that little green the green sword at
the top
and then a little bit later in the video
it was yeah this red
this red hand was that about
let's see when does the red hand appear
okay right there he's using a sword
and then when it shifts to the next
section right here does he not have a
sword anymore
he's got yeah he still has a sword right
there isn't that a sword
this what is this like some sort of claw
thing
the Dark Brotherhood what is going on
with that I bet those are like maybe
special abilities or something
oh well hold on it's something different
here is that a cape
okay wait it just
okay hold on that's something to do with
this glider I think
or no no no it just means when you're
gliding he can't use it see watch it
goes it turns gray right there
and then when he lands again it turns
green I can't tell if it's supposed to
be a cape or if it's like some sort of
uh oh that's that ability they showed us
that's the ability they just showed us
of him being able to go through
the roof let's double check here
yeah yeah I think that's what that is
and so then what does that mean that the
hand one
okay the sword is that when they were
showing us the fusing right here
so that must be the indicator for the
using go ninja welcome in welcome in
how's it going
let's see I think when they're still
showing the sword I think that's the
fusing
oh another little indicator right there
different symbol
okay so that one's kind of like a
a light orange kind of brown color oh
okay yeah so that's that's the new
ability so that one right there is
rewind
so I guess this is kind of like
symbolizing the time rewinding and then
so the the green one that's got to be
the
the fuse
and so then this one is whatever he was
doing here like
I don't know why it's a hand though
why do you think it's a hand
that's like when he was fusing them
together molding them together Ultra
hand okay there so that one's called
Ultra hand
Ultra hand fuse
let's see do they show us the names of
the other ones
recall so yeah recall
fuse Ultra hand
and then Ascend was the other one so
that's what each of those icons is for
as well
Ultra hand I yeah I'm not sure that's
fitting for what
I guess it works
they probably described it
let's see if they uh we'll lift up this
thing is
ability can be called
here we go it's a makeshift raft this is
another new ability called Ultra hand
even though the logs are currently
attached they can be detached let's
modify the shape of the raft
so it's just what kind of makes them
stick together there
so you can grab then once you grab
you've got forward back rotate
and then use the right stick if you want
to unstick
one of the pieces we put this on the
water it's made of wood so the buoyancy
will keep it afloat really apparently
Ultra hand was the name of a Nintendo
toy
boat interesting never heard of that it
won't move in its current state Ken you
don't think there's a chica slate in
this game
his new arm is the new Chica slate oh
dude I was wondering what was going on
with the arm right there beneficial for
hunting it's the right arm isn't it
let's see can you see it in the
beginning here okay left arm looks
normal
we call them Sky Islands
oh you may be right no chica slate
silence when they're so high up
if we take a look oh oh come on show the
right side we're almost at the spot
where the object fell
there you go there's a there's a the
best look probably gonna get it right
there
see when he kind of runs over
oh yeah yeah yeah I think you're right
dude I wonder if we'll see a story
explanation for that
if we'll see something who knows maybe
they've already explained this in
another trailer or something and I
didn't see it but yeah it almost looks
like that sort of uh mechanical
material from the first game
zodiac welcome in
I think Zelda takes the Slate based on
the trailer I think it's the arm
from the God holding ganon's body down
based on one of the other trailers
all right hold on we may need to uh
many to watch another trailer here real
quick
I thought I'd seen all the Zelda
trailers but maybe I haven't
let's see scrolling back through here
when was their last trailer
oh goodness it's probably a lot faster
if I just uh okay wait here we go
official trailer two
did I not watch this
we'll find out
this is number two so there's the other
trailer the first trailer
oh the first trailer shows the arm
okay shows you how long ago I watched it
I guess
dude that Dragon over there
I love you
oh wait am I watching I'm watching the
wrong language
I thought it was just part of the uh
the enemy or something
all right hold on tears of the Kingdom
let's just go in order
trailer one
all right here we go
okay so this was the first trailer
a minute and a half long
Jesse how's it going
when did this when did this trailer come
out
six months ago
yeah
I'm definitely now I gotta remember any
of this
it's very uh solemn start here
okay so you guys so apparently no chica
slate okay see right there it looks like
link from the last game the arms they're
both covered though
sure many people oh there we go there
you can see the the right arm is
different
[Music]
well that was the shortest trailer ever
oh man okay
all right that's trailer one
trailer two
official trailer two all right oh First
Look trailer yeah that's the one I was
thinking of from three years ago
oh yeah yeah that one that one that one
that's why they're called teasers right
yeah there was a there was a trailer
before trailer one which is this one
here
yeah now I definitely remember watching
this one
because this was when it first got
revealed right this was was this the
reveal trailer
First Look trailer E3 2019
[Music]
show us your right hand link
I want to see what it was like in that
scene
oh right there
whoa okay whoa
a lot happening with the hand very
quickly so is that supposed to be Gannon
right there
the dude that was that dead thing
anybody watching this back they're like
retro you're such a noob dude
this has already been known for months
years now
okay yeah so that that's when we're
there like it's now in development okay
now official trailer two hopefully in
English this time let's see
okay we don't know for sure thank you
three teasers that are all painfully
short
yeah definitely something going on with
the arm though you guys are totally
right about that and there was that one
shot in the last one
look at that on the right is that like a
three-headed dragon
a three-headed flaming dragon
he sounds angry
why is he so angry for
oh
right there I am not sure you'll be able
to stop him
[Music]
oh there was the eyeball right there
there we go
oh yeah clearly look at the focus on the
hand right there oh what are these
little uh
these little capsules right here in the
kind of green
[Music]
oh and there's one of those falling
things where they just
they taught us what that's all about
oh wait wait there's more there's more
[Music]
please lend him your power
so she is asking
some sort of god or goddess to lend us
their power is my guess
please lend him your power yeah lend him
your power
and is our hand normal right there
I mean it looks it looks dark but it
doesn't look
doesn't have that like
mechanical look to it yet
oh man so cool
May 12 2023
that is like just under two months away
Professor Baxter welcome in welcome in
Matt Mercer is that is it confirmed Matt
Mercer it does it definitely sounds like
it for sure
when link jumps to grab Zelda the hand
that he was holding releases from Gana
to catch him oh you think that's when he
gets the power
Zelda had powers from hylia in the first
game
oh maybe so maybe so
all right well I'm even more hyped now
after watching that
but
we have another game coming out even
before that one
Star Wars Jedi Survivor
official story trailer uh if you guys
didn't know we have been streaming this
live over on Twitch
part one of our let's play of this game
hits our let's play Channel tomorrow
and so I'm gonna watch this trailer now
too
gonna watch this one now Jake what's up
dude welcome in
dude imagine if it could be like this
every week if we just have like all
these new trailers we can watch
and react to all right this one's
shorter than the the Zelda one was like
13 minutes Star Wars Jedi Survivor
official story trailer I haven't been
the story of the first game but
if I'm spoiled oh well
oh my goodness already
Graphics look a lot better
[Music]
fear and mistrust rule the galaxy
oh my goodness
cow
look into the fire
he's rocking a beard now
unchecked
it will consume everything
until there is only oh the wall run
how could you let the Galaxy fall to
this unworthy machine of an Empire
hopes may feel Beyond her grasp
I think we finally found somewhere the
Empire can't reach us
imagine
no more looking over your shoulder
what a place that's worth fighting for
no matter the cost
oh my goodness dude let's go
it's not on Xbox One
oh because it's is it next it's next gen
only right
so let's see if they say in the
description here
available on PlayStation 5 yeah Xbox
series X and S and PC April 28 2023
pre-order now to outfit Cal with the
Obi-Wan Kenobi inspired Jedi survival
cosmetic pack
well now I gotta take a peek at that
I have to take a peek
okay wait deluxe edition oh man here we
go with all these additions again
okay so you can pre-order the standard
and you get the Jedi survival cosmetic
pack where's that at
uh this right here okay pre-order any
addition to receive the Obi-Wan Kenobi
inspired Jedi survival cosmetic pack
hermit cosmetic combustion Blaster and
the hermit lightsaber oh man yeah that's
an iconic lightsaber right there
and then they also have a deluxe edition
that includes the base game
Jedi survival cosmetic pack same as
their deluxe edition exclusive new hero
cosmetic and then the galactic hero
cosmetic what is it like ten dollars
more
the scoundrel okay so we got like this
Han Solo look going on the rugged bd1
dl44 Blaster okay so we're gonna be
getting blasters in this one maybe we
get them in the first game too and I
just haven't made it that far yet but
I think that might be a new thing Rebel
hero lightsaber BD Astro bd1 cosmetic I
like that one and then Rebel hero
cosmetic
how much is the deluxe edition
does it not tell you
89.99
what
20 dollars more
chat
heck
hey Dylan with the eight months
welcome in dude
we're just talking about one of your
favorite
franchises here
have you already pre-ordered which one
you going for Dylan you going for the uh
you going for the deluxe
hey Patrick what is up dude the chill808
with the five gifted memberships Patrick
thank you so much man
we'll see who got some of those gifteds
May May Day Care M lot Chase Templar
gaming what's up Templar you're a wizard
Harry
welcome into the new members welcome in
guys to house rack and tour thank you
all for being here hanging out tonight
we are getting caught up on some of the
latest gaming news we already watched
the Zelda tears of the Kingdom
uh new gameplay that Nintendo released
today
looks really cool I still have some
concerns that it'll be
not enough of the stuff I love about
Zelda I have no doubt it'll be a great
game though no doubt it'd be a great
game Star Wars Jedi Survivor just
watched the official story trailer
that's looking good a little
disappointed in this uh these editions
surely there's something I'm missing
here right
twenty dollars more for just
just the cosmetics what that's crazy
right
going Deluxe anyway for this is that it
though like I'm not if you wanna if
people want to spend the twenty dollars
on it go for it but I'm just like wait
is that it
I was thinking ten dollars Max for the
difference there
all right I'm scrolling back up to catch
up with
we did Jose yeah yeah it makes it real
easy to go back and YouTube makes it
pretty easy to rewind so if you want to
rewind to the beginning and check that
out and then uh you can like skip ahead
or fast forward 2x speed whatever you
want but yeah we uh we started off
we kind of chatted for I don't know
about 15 20 minutes and then we jumped
into Zelda so if I had to guess I would
say it's probably around the 15 20
minute Mark of the Stream
well they gotta hide all the Obi-Wan
stuff behind pre-orders and you know
they're gonna have some awesome stuff
actually in the main game too
but Patrick thank you so much dude for
the gift it's good to see you here
tonight my friend
you've always wondered how I remember
your name I
who knows Jake who knows
I feel probably because you're just like
a loyal visitor in the streams most
likely
JP you'd go for deluxe if you had a PS5
man 20 bucks for cosmetics
I can't justify that
me personally me personally
no blaster in fallen over okay so that's
a new thing
yeah I saw the cross guard too on the
lightsaber
nice
oh yeah yeah the whole uh Hogwart the
collector's edition the Hogwarts Legacy
deluxe edition was uh it was only ten
dollars more that was that was a solid
deal
a solid deal I think
four dollars on Steam right now oh
falling over I was like wait what
four dollars no I I got it for free uh
through well I guess not technically
free but PlayStation Plus
so yeah we've been playing it on PS5
blow money like it's going out of style
even you were like
like nah
oh my gosh JP
different type of Cosmetics here
different type of cosmetics
delayed PS4 Hogwarts Legacy wait
wait you don't mean again do you
you don't mean like it's still May right
I didn't miss something while I've been
streaming have I
oh my gosh did I
I saw there was a new tweet from
Chandler but he was just posting about
their uh
their Hogwarts Legacy live tomorrow yeah
yeah Baxter I did I did see that I think
we talked about it a few a few weeks ago
on the live
Skye how do you feel about the fact that
the purple bounty hunters is not
killable when he loses his limbs it will
Stitch back together
what so wait is that did we see that in
the trailer did I miss that
oh is that this yeah hold on that this
guy right right here that dude
so they're not killable when they lose
limbs it will Stitch back together what
[Music]
I didn't even know about that so yeah I
don't know I mean I try like respawns a
great Dev and they did a good job of the
first game so
I would hope they have some good
gameplay mechanic behind it behind why
they're doing it oh that's like official
lore
ah
okay
so this so you're saying is it confirmed
that that's how the game's gonna be
handling it
hey Nico what is up Nico thank you for
the five gifteds you're a wizard how's
it going Nico hope you're having a good
night ma'am
hope you're having a good night
appreciate the five gifteds looks like
let's see Tom
Carrie big evil pixie lady
all just got one of those gifteds from
Nico and then JP raven fire got one of
the gifteds as well let's go
guys enjoy the emote switch oh my gosh
we're covering other games man we're
gonna have to uh gonna have to Branch
out on the emotes
I haven't checked in forever to see if
we
I don't know if we have more slots
available or not on YouTube
probably not
I feel like we maxed I feel like we uh
the last time I hit a really high number
of open slots I think I filled them all
oh my gosh baby Yoda
grogu that'd be great
it just becomes like we have all sorts
of uh
nerd culture emotes
that um
my son had his book fair the other day
he cracks me up because he loves to read
and he loves like going to the library
and picking out books but for some
reason every time this book fair rolls
around
he'll just come home with the most
random
non-book things
so this most recent one he comes home
with a grogu poster
oh man I cracked up I'm like you haven't
even seen
he's not he's eight he's too young to
watch Mandalore I don't know he might be
able to
uh he could definitely watch the Star
Wars movies but Mandalorian I'm like and
it gets a little
like you haven't even seen anything Star
Wars related
but he's like I like Star Wars it's like
okay well I guess we gotta get we gotta
introduce you to uh
maybe at least uh what's the cartoon the
Clone Wars
that might be a good one to start to
start him with
all right Star Wars Star Wars uh fans in
the chat
for for a young lad that we want to
introduce him to the Star Wars
franchise
where
do we even begin
right
I'm curious I'm curious what do you what
do you guys think where do we get new
New Hope Cloud ROTC that's that's kind
of what I'm thinking too
you eventually have to see I mean you
got to show the prequels though at some
point I actually think at his age right
now I think he'd probably love the
prequels to be honest
I think it would especially Phantom
Menace I think he would like that a lot
Clone Wars is very uh the the show I've
never watched any of the
oh it's very serious
didn't know that
what did uh Timothy what did your
brother think as a nine-year-old what
did he think about them
this man like when I when I go try to
show my son old games he's just like
this looks terrible
it's so hard for him to get past that
just gift the sequel zodiac said
start in order of the timeline
no more looking over your shoulder
machete's order what the heck is that I
haven't even heard of this
oh man when did I get into when did I
see my first Star Wars
goodness
because I actually saw
I actually saw the prequels first I'm
almost positive I saw those first
and then I rented
I rented The Originals on I think it was
on VHS dude
Dylan says four five one two three six
start with Rebels
foreign
new dog says wait what do you mean you
mean um
is there was there a show called Rebels
more details on the Bounty Hunter look
up durge Star Wars
saw the preak was as a kid then yeah
that's exactly what I did
this unworthy machine of an Empire
this dude here
a fearsome male gendai Bounty Hunter
active during the clone wars in the
Imperial era
personality and traits Infamous and
fearsome durge worked as a bounty hunter
on his own time he enjoyed his
reputation for being hard to kill openly
mentioning it to Aphra and staros I'm
probably
Star Wars fans be gentle please I'm not
like an expert on Star Wars shortly
after meeting them I was more than
willing to strike down his enemies even
if it meant bringing about the extension
Extinction of a species he was also
taller than average height of 1.56
meters
where's this whole ordeal about him like
regrowing limbs or whatever
hey Stargazer Tim what is up dude
welcome in
thank you for the six months Tim do the
next half a year standing on my head
maybe not still looking forward to it
been a blast retro hey Tim love these
well dude lumos to you my friend thank
you
good to see you here
machetes order old machetes order
what okay I've never heard of this I
gotta look this up too
new dog thanks for stopping by have a
good one
appreciate your oh there's a show called
Rebels
a less serious Clone Wars
gotcha see there's so many
there's so many options when it comes to
Star Wars Rebels
and then the other thing I wanted to
look up was
Star Wars I thought you guys were
goofing around see like I
it's like machete's order what the heck
what is this
all right how to watch the Star Wars
movies in order here's why the machete
order is the way you should watch the
Star Wars saga
what in the world
oh it's exactly what we're talking about
you guys maybe we'll even be introducing
a younger viewer to the films for their
first time or maybe you just fancy
re-watching the entire Grand Star Wars
narrative blah blah blah
okay wait
why read on okay
the original machete order was
formulated before Star Wars the Force
awakens Last Jedi in Rise of Skywalker
D3 has added these films in now
they've been released however they have
no effect on the machete order as other
spin-off movies and TV shows like Rogue
one and solo have zero bearing on the
core Skywalker Saga story they are not
included
Why episode order fails
I've never heard about this episode
order is the order in which George Lucas
supposedly envisioned his Grand
narrative all along Phantom Menace
attack of the Clones Revenge of the Sith
New Hope Empire Jedi force awakens Last
Jedi rise of Skywalker surely then
nothing can go wrong with this order
right after all it's the order of the
grand narrative that George meticulously
planned out over decades wrong George
had no Grand narrative other than that
which involved dump truckloads
of Dosh
I've never heard this word
a British a slang word for money okay
I was thinking it probably had to be
something like that
in fact there are two obviously critical
flaws wow
especially if you're watching the films
for the first time
firstly and this is a real doozy of a
flaw by watching the films in episode
order the dramatic surprise
true Revelation that Darth Vader is Luke
Skywalker's father is completely and
utterly ruined one of the most memorable
scenes in the entirety of movie history
ruined why well far from only getting
small hints that loose father is Vader
which is what you get if you just watch
A New Hope and Empire Strikes Back the
prequel trilogy completely spunks away
the Revelation ramming it down your
throat with an appalling Anakin being
turned into Vader transition scene
at the end of Revenge of the Sith
dude that's that's right
as such by the time a new viewer comes
around to watching Empire The Dramatics
seeing surprises not only ruined but the
emotional impact rendered null and void
so true if that wasn't bad enough
episode order also makes very little
sense from a narrative point of view all
three of the prequel films are
essentially background material for the
original trilogy's narrative and as
George decided to clumsily
shift narrative Focus between the two
trilogies from Luke to Anakin Vader it
doesn't even do that job well spending
hours focusing on the latter's motives
for turning evil in one of the most
boring character development arcs of all
time completely disjoint I mean tell us
how you really feel who's the author of
this
uh Robert tell us how you really feel
Robert
all right so I get it I get it then they
say release order is no better
the machete order
all right here we go ladies and
gentlemen so how do you solve these
three experienced ruining issues for the
viewer simple you watch the films in
this order
A New Hope
The Empire Strikes Back
of the Clones
okay wait so they go attack the Clones
after Empire
huh interesting
so A New Hope Empire attack of the
Clones Revenge of the Sith Return of the
Jedi
oh my gosh
and then the force awakens The Last Jedi
rise of Skywalker yes you read that
right Phantom Menace is not included
Phantom Menace is not included oh my
goodness see I feel like an
eight-year-old would actually really
like Phantom Menace though
by watching the films in this order you
not only avoid spoilers entirely but
also maintain the original narrative's
Focus essentially you follow Luke on his
coming-of-age story up until he loses
his hand to Vader on Cloud City and
finds out that he is his father before
going on an extended to film flashback
where we see how Anakin became Vader and
conceived Luke before then snapping back
to the present for the finale the father
reveal is preserved the Luke narrative
is preserved and the ghost-tastic
feel-good Redemption finale is preserved
but you may say how do we get the whole
story without UPS of one without episode
one surely it has an effect on narrative
nope nope and nope episode one is
completely Superfluous to the story and
all the narrative strands it raises are
essentially concluded within the same
film
for example Darth Maul has no bearing
outside the film on the story and is
replaced immediately with Count Dooku
equally Qui-Gon Jin's actions have no
bearing outside the film and he may as
well not have existed
dude don't say that about Qui-Gon
everything Anakin does in the film as a
boy is irrelevant to The Wider plot all
characters who pass over to episode 2
are also reintroduced along with their
motives the list goes on the brutal fact
is that episode 1 is just not needed and
when you've got Jar Jar Binks devouring
your soul in every other seat
it's just not worth it
all right I'm not gonna read all this oh
my goodness
I I'm so glad you guys brought this up
wait oh hold up hold up we got we got
Dustin and and Dr sherwick coming out
violently violently against
okay so wait Patrick the chill 808 and I
think Dylan both strongly strongly on
the side of machete order here
Dustin and Dr Sherbert saying machete
order is blasphemy shame Dr sherbet
shouts
okay wait Tim weighing in now too that's
gonna mess up anyone who goes back to
clone wars and Rebels animated series
wondering who this small character is
and he is important true
very true
oh gotcha Skye I might check I might
check that out here in a bit
Qui-Gon and Darth Maul are major in the
overall arc when you include the other
stuff
that list made me
Patrick Dylan get in here and defend
this defend defend the machete order
here
this is too funny
four five two three six
wait hold on I'm scrolling back up to
where
where was Dylan Dylan weighing in okay
four yep five
yep
oh wait hold on Dylan's was slightly
okay wait maybe this is not this is not
the same machete order that Dylan said
Dylan said four which is a New Hope five
which is Empire
and then Dylan had had us going straight
into
Return of the Jedi
wait sherbet machete's order is the
order I just stated oh okay hold on I
misread I misread okay so Dylan gave us
machete order
but Dylan says he's gonna show them to
his daughter in the order of four five
six then one two three
okay all right so wait I Patrick you
might be all alone trying to defend this
you might be alone trying to defend this
machete order
Phantom Menace is basically a lot of
political stuff that is true there's
some of that as well
don't watch the Christmas special didn't
even know there was such a thing
you might want to end with Return of the
Jedi
the sequels were horrible doctor show oh
my God
strong opinions man dude Star Wars
always brings out these kinds of
opinions people
like here's my take
and
don't don't jump on me please
please I watched
one
did I watch all three of them as a kid
first I don't think so I think I
probably watched Phantom Menace
maybe clone wars and then
saw the originals
revenge of the sit and like I enjoyed
them
obviously the originals are a lot better
but I like I enjoyed them as a kid
haven't watched them in years and then I
I enjoyed the newer ones too like I
didn't I dude
I do have to say though man like
spoilers if you guys haven't seen the
whatever they're calling them the latest
in the Star Wars movies
um
floating floating Leia
like from outside the ship
oh my gosh I almost I almost started
laughing in the theater
like actually just just bursting out
laughing in the theater I I almost did
oh my goodness but like I enjoyed them
but but it's also because I don't I'm
not as passionate about them as like die
hard fans you know like like Harry
Potter stuff I'm so
hyper aware and hyper-critical of things
I'm gonna critique and really look for
certain things but with Star Wars I'm
just like eh you know I'm just just here
for
zodiac had no direction for the sequels
even Luke said not to watch the sequels
yeah it's like I uh
they're they're they're kind of
forgettable
forgettable for me I guess
some cool pretty cool action scenes
though
Patrick with the 20 20 Super Chat just
machete order is all it says
Patrick thank you so much for the 20
dude appreciate it my friend
Timothy you watched seven one two three
eight four five six nine
Phantom Menace is garbage even Lucas
said he just he did it just to give his
kids something hey well I've got an
eight-year-old so maybe we do need to
watch that
seven was okay just a 4K version of four
yeah I did I did not enjoy the Luke Arc
didn't enjoy that
um
but like some of the fights like the
fights with kylo Ren and stuff I felt
like that was cool
what Dustin oh my God
Dustin with the fifty dollar Super Chat
Phantom matters
the battle begins
right Jenny like what is happening
Patrick with the 20 to say machete order
Dustin
coming in hot with the 50 saying Phantom
matters
oh my goodness
go play a video game or
don't ruin don't ruin a franchise with
the kids
uh Panther I saw four five six when I
I saw four five six when I saw them
measure Anakin's power it totally ruined
it for me or are you talking about the
whole uh
midichlorian thing
he found Revenge of the Sith the best
one me store
uh oh man you guys
he's about to break out into the debates
the debates here in the chat
take start with book of Boba Fett hey
wait wait Rogue one Rogue one anybody
Rogue one was pretty good where's the
love for rogue one maybe we started
maybe you start with Mandalorian dude
start with Mandalorian
have a good night Ken thank you for
being here dude
Rogue okay wait wait we're getting some
agreement here
while the arguing happens look at Jin
Jin die oh yeah yeah we forgot I forgot
about this here all right so yeah we
were looking at this dude here
and then you said g-e-n
okay here we go
oh yeah he does he looks just like the
guy in the game okay so seemingly
Immortal formless species which
originated on an unidentified planet in
the galaxy devoid of any bones the
jindai typically wore heavy armor to
give themselves a humanoid structure oh
wow so they're not even like
with most of his armor Blown Away by a
missile also that's what they actually
look like
that's creepy
a boneless species with large fangs
virtually a formless jumble of corded
muscle and nerve bundles
what
average lifespan four thousand to seven
thousand standard years
and so that's what that dude is in the
game
oh man
so we're not we're probably not going to
be able to take him out
maybe only escape from him or something
Rogue one was so good rogue rogue one
was epic Rogue one was very good Baxter
says pretty good Dustin says good I
agree
Skye oh Skye says it was only good for
the ending scene
now for a real hot take solo I have
actually haven't seen solo Dr sherbet
that is one that I have not seen
all right
let's see how long we've been going oh
my gosh it's almost been two hours all
right let's move to the Final Fantasy
trailer I promised at least one more
trailer
one more trailer oh yeah we might watch
this one too actually since we're still
on the Star Wars kick let's uh
all right so I've never heard of this
game you guys were telling me earlier to
watch the trailer for Star Wars eclipse
uh this is from all the way from
December 2021 so this is an old trailer
but I'm not seeing it it's the newest
Adventure in the high Republic era in
early developer
I can't read early in development by
Quantic dream
Quantic dream fantastic studio for
a lot of uh
like story driven Choice based games
like heavy rain Detroit become human I
never played Detroit but I really
enjoyed Heavy Rain thought Heavy Rain
was awesome
so they're calling this one though
okay so they are calling it an adventure
yeah intricately branching
action-adventure game
that can be experienced in many ways and
puts the Destinies of multiple playable
characters in your hands created in
collaboration between Quantic dream and
lucasfilm games
this is why we got to do more streams
like this man I had no idea this existed
eight almost 19 million views somehow I
missed it okay here we go
so this is probably like mostly concept
here
I don't know how long it's been in
development so I don't know how much
they had to show for this
[Music]
because Heavy Rain I loved heavy rain
having a game that has so many different
endings and so many ways that you can
impact the story
Yoda
ah so they're not gonna show us any like
I want to see some dialogue and some of
the characters
I mean it looks fantastic but
they're these typically like Quantic
dream it's very little like
it's not gameplay heavy
Voldemort is that you
what the heck
[Music]
all right all right
Star Wars
eclipse.com it says down here not actual
gameplay yeah I mean cool like
looks cool looks like they're going to
be covering a lot of cool stuff but it's
hard it's hard to judge much from that
we gotta see more
we gotta see like actual
because heavy rain in Detroit I mean
they're they're similar but
and I would guess that this is going to
be in that kind of same mold
you said the same thing when you solved
you said Voldemort too you think it will
release next year new story yeah that's
what I was gonna say next like have
there been have there been any kind of
updates on this game or anything guys
looks like we had had some news five
months ago
upcoming Star Wars games
oh 2025 is that what people are guessing
for that one
I know there's a there's like a bunch of
uh plan playing Star Wars games
Patrick I saw you were saying when you
see it now you just die a little inside
you remember being blown away as a kid
with Empire
I mean at least there's still some good
things like I haven't seen the latest
season of Mandalorian yet but I've I've
enjoyed that what I've seen of that so
far
and I need to start is are all the
episodes out by the way yet of the new
season I want to wait till everything's
out so I can just go crazy binge it
Darth Revan movie is that actually
something that they're trying to do
what
it could be tomorrow with how secretive
they are uh
on the eclipse eclipse info
not yet on the Mandalorian okay I'll
wait a few more weeks then
you're enjoying this season oh no are
people not liking this one don't tell me
anything don't tell me
I'll see I'll watch it at some point
but yeah I mean at least you got the
game to look forward to Patrick I'm
pretty sure Jedi Survivor will be good
I don't know about the about story wise
but I mean I feel pretty confident in
the gameplay
all right man as riveting as the Star
Wars conversation has been
let's shift into our final trailer for
the night at least I think final trailer
for Final Fantasy 16 now I'll tell you
guys right now I have not played
a Final Fantasy game in
a long time I know how incredibly
popular though they still are I have the
Final Fantasy VII remake
that you know what guys that actually
I can't decide if I'm gonna stream that
or if it's just gonna be a let's play
like only like record for YouTube only
and post it to the let's play Channel
so if you're interested at all on that
and you're not yet uh following our
let's play Channel make sure you follow
that youtube.com at retro raconteur
let's plays
but um
yeah man I don't know if I want to play
that on Twitch or
or just record it for YouTube
Cloud Roth says stream it live one of
your favorites of all time
because I play obviously played the
original way way way back in the day but
I have not played the new one even
though I have it I don't know I think I
bought it because it was like a it was
on sale or something I'm like sure I'll
buy it for that price
um
yeah man I played let's see I played
nine
as a kid
I played the demo of eight I never
played eight all the way through I
played nine
and then I think
I think that might be the last one I
played guys
played
but let's see maybe I you know it you
can always come back you can always come
back let's let's check out this trailer
here so this is Final Fantasy 16 the
world of
Valencia
official trailer
just gonna assume I said that totally
correct
[Music]
so the graphics look awesome
oh come on show us some some battles
this is the this is a very new trailer
this was just released a few days ago
oh come on is this all they're gonna
show
I mean everything looks great some of
these locations look awesome
I want to see the gameplay though show
us the show us the gameplay let's see
what we're gonna be doing
already saw a gameplay recently okay
so we might need to watch another
trailer
what that was it okay wait new gameplay
oh this was at PAX East
oh wait hold on let's see whose uh video
this is okay this is GameSpot
oh so they went like a deep dive here
huh
The Narrative the characters the visuals
the battle system
most importantly um is our battle
systems
so our dedication has been to create
this exciting combat system that for the
first time in the series okay new
gameplay footage right here let's watch
this
I only stand here today okay here we go
15 years I've waited for this chance
from a gutter killed more men that I can
count
uh-oh music
what is the battle system like chat
is it term-based
because this this does not look
term-based
my lady
ready
action RPG oh my gosh
okay I'm I'm more interested now
what
are these the summons
okay dude that looks Epic
that looks taken right out of God of War
battling the Titans
oh dude
that looks great
the world breakdown made from five
different nations and one neutral
city-state
so is it is it open world
I'm excited to hear its action RPG
oh you guys would like term based better
yeah I'm more I'm more uh
I like those as a kid but I don't know
the older I get I just don't care for
them as much
it's a mix between
Final Fantasy 15 and remake okay I
haven't played remake yet but I have
that on my list
I have that on my list
hey Skye it was good chatting with you
have a good night thank you for being
here you can catch the you can catch the
end later in the in the VOD it'll stay
up here on the channel
hard to find your name in the sea of
green oh on you is it because wait it's
different on uh twitch isn't it
then he talks about the world breakdown
here
so is this gonna be like free roam open
world
okay so they talk about the narrative
what do they say about the narrative
High fantasy yes
that's what I enjoy while weaving a deep
um and sweeping narrative complete with
politics conflict and intrigue
okay
but also with older players like me I'm
gonna be 50 years old this year and we
already know how harsh the real world
can be
um
and our second pillar is our characters
all right so narrative battle system
World breakdown oh here's more gameplay
right here gameplay of various areas
because that trailer we just watched was
just them walking around I want to see
some action
oh is this just gonna be walking around
too
wait is this the same thing this is what
we just watched
so we just watched
so maybe that's not new I thought there
was like a new trailer just the other
day
oh here we go
is this what they
okay they ended it with the
iconic abilities
wow that combat is really really fast
when does this come out
anybody know
man this is a crazy year for games
I mean are you kidding me
a new Final Fantasy A new Zelda
a new Spider-Man game this year
we had Hogwarts Legacy this year
a new freaking Zelda game this year
June 22nd Thank you new store
I mean Resident Evil 4 just came out
like
this year for games you guys is just
amazing
[Music]
just amazing
I feel like there's one more big one
that I'm forgetting too Starfield yes
Starfield and then I think there's
some of these are gonna get pushed right
but then we still don't even know about
many of the big November games and stuff
I think star field is probably because
Spider-Man the latest rumor on
Spider-Man is September
summer is going to be crazy that's for
sure
that is for sure
always Starfield September as well
okay so let's look at this let's look
here 2023
video game release dates
upcoming games release schedule
all right so we are about into April
let's see I'm just looking for like
which is looking for like some of the
big name titles
Advance Wars one two reboot camp on
switch in April
Star Wars Jedi survival is April Jedi
Survivor is April 28th
uh Minecraft Legends April 18th
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection ghost wire Tokyo on Xbox
is in April
EA Sports PGA Tour 2023 meet your makers
April
all right so that's April May we got red
fall
Hogwarts Legacy on PS4 Xbox One Legend
of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
Lego 2K Drive Lord of the Rings Gollum
is in uh may now
which wasn't there a new trailer of that
recently
I think there was but
we've already watched enough trailers
because the the first couple trailers I
saw for that I was just like eh
I wasn't really feeling it
birthdays in two weeks
oh yeah it's Dead Island two Baldur
Skate 3 Diablo Diablo is the big one I'm
forgetting oh my gosh Diablo's gonna be
huge
what month is Diablo June
Diablo is going to be massive Okay so
uh so that was some of the big Suicide
Squad
we'll see right we'll see
it's not been looking good
which is so surprising man Rocksteady is
just
they did such a good job on Batman
all right so June oh my gosh listen to
this June Street Fighter 6 Diablo 4
Final Fantasy 16. those are all in June
right there
uh July you got Pikmin 4 maybe Hogwarts
Legacy on the switch
okay then it's then it's looking a
little bit more sparse August Baldur's
Gate three
Texas Chainsaw Massacre sea of stars
those are all in August
September right now so star field is
September 6th the latest rumor is that
Spider-Man 2 is also going to be
September
and then October November December
looking pretty light
there's only one confirmed title
according to Gamespot here sword art
online last recollection
is October and then November the day
before I'm not familiar with that but
the day before
dude so we don't even know about
I mean you know there's gonna be some
big holiday games
coming out October November December
you don't want to be old
it's all I mean once I once I hit a
certain age I just stop I like
I just try not to think about the number
too much Patrick
just don't think about the number age is
just a number
okay and then still to be announced
Alan Wake two
Assassin's Creed Mirage saw the rumor
that might be delayed
uh just I'm just scanning there's a lot
of games I'm just scanning for some of
the big ones here
Forza Motorsport
Frozen flame Ghostbusters rise of the
ghost Lord that's a VR game
ghost Runner 2
Hollow Knight silk song
that will be a big one
Marvel's midnight Suns Marvel Spider-Man
2.
all right it's a long list I'm not gonna
look through all these
I'm gonna read through all of them but
yeah I mean that's crazy that all those
game all those big time like heavy
hitting games are
basically this summer and then August
and September
so yeah
that's that is nuts October November
December is still pretty clear some of
them might get pushed though you never
know
Spider-Man that that one's not official
yet that one could easily
I mean if if October and November just
stay this wide open they might just want
to wait
skull and bones
you think it's good Dustin thinks it's
gonna flop
oh man
well this was fun man this was fun I
hope you guys enjoyed this a little bit
of a different style stream
but I think we're gonna go ahead and
wrap it up here
um I'm hoping to go live on YouTube
tomorrow
what do you guys more anxious to see you
want to see more Star Wars or you want
to see more
Lord retro more Hogwarts Legacy
I'm curious to those of you hanging out
to those of you who are those of you who
are still here at the end of this stream
you're like you're like the hardcore
you're the die hards
so I will ask you guys what you want to
see more of
Jenny with the tier one
there you go getting that membership
back
nice thank you Jenny Dr sherbet says
Star Wars Dustin says more retro in
general
Patrick says do what you want oh man
which one do I want to play more
probably Star Wars honestly
nah I'm not gonna do a poll we've only
got there's about what 30 34 or so
watching
there's plenty of room for you guys to
chat here voice your opinion
Mia says retro more JP says all the
things
Dr sherbet says change it up I can't I
honestly Dr Sherbert you know what I
really had the itch to play it's
Resident Evil 4.
I really would have played Resident
before but I got I gotta start knocking
out some of these games before I start
something else
I have to I just I just I have to
so like I've already beaten Hogwarts I
obviously want to platinum it but
and since I'm going just doing story
stuff it's not going to take me as long
but yeah I gotta be I gotta at least
finish and I'm also playing Metroid
Prime for
for the let's play channel so that's
three games I'm playing right now now
fortunately two of them have already
beaten before so but like Star Wars if
I'm being honest with you guys like Star
Wars is what I have the itch to play
because I haven't I haven't beaten it I
want to beat that game
foreign
what's up
you want to cast your your vote Rochelle
you won't play any of those you'll watch
me play him a sounds good Jenny
Tim Driver's Choice do what you enjoy
Cloud Ross says don't matter Patrick
says I like variety
Mia did your first run as a Slytherin
second as Gryffindor oh yeah
yep I'm doing the exact opposite
which last time we just we finally
learned we finally learned crucio
and then chat tried to get me not to use
it
you were leading the charge Dustin don't
think I forgot it either
don't think I forgot it
oh my gosh Baxter
don't even remind me about that
you're right you are right yeah we
started
I think we just have one I think we just
did one let's play of the
Order of the Phoenix
now I need to go back and find this
let's see
did we live stream it though
I feel like I live stream oh no no I I
did I live streamed it on Twitch and
then we reposted it
yes there was a
yeah we did episode one on the main
channel so we would have to move that
over to the second Channel
well not move that episode I'm not going
to touch that but
from then on we would put put it on the
let's place oh you just had to remind me
yes so we've got that one
hanging over us too
[Music]
see this is the challenge you guys
there's just not there's not enough time
even with this being what I do now
there's not enough time
I mean I I definitely see why
you have like people go all in on
streaming or all in on YouTube and then
the ones that do both it's like they
start to hire out people to help them
with the editing
because for me to keep up doing two
videos a week
I just like I can't stream every day I
can't like three days like three
streaming three days a week is kind of
like my
oh no am I are we still live I just got
a thing saying OBS Studio disconnected
wait wait wait are we here reconnection
successful
no idea what that was about I don't know
if you guys can hear me or not
I'm still live okay
Windows popped up and said OBS
disconnected that freaked me out
oh it lagged for a second OBS man
what was I saying though oh yeah like
it's just like
the editing and so I'm I'm getting I'm
starting to get to that point where it's
like oh should I look for somebody to
edit for me
should I look for somebody
to edit
I mean it's a lot of money that's like
big downside right
but it can save you a lot of time it can
save you a lot of time
because I feel like a lot of you guys
just love like I feel like you guys
would show up for streams every day I do
I could show up if I live stream every
day plus I'd get to knock out a lot more
games that way too
foreign
for a little bit yeah that was that was
weird at least we're at the end
Lord retro Mort would get an intern to
edit for free
you can learn how to edit do it from
home there's my work from home job
Dustin I'm not I'm not big I'm not that
big yet
I'm not that big
she's one of my boys oh my gosh that's
actually low-key that's that's a good
idea a great skill for them to learn my
son even wants to start making some
videos that'd be a great like I could be
like okay
you want to do this
here here's how you will you will start
out
here's what I need to become a master at
Nico you say you would watch live
streams every day
would I need to become a master at is
being able to take
content from live streams
and turn it into
good YouTube content
dude if I could master that and figure
out a formula for that we would be set
like these videos though that you guys
like all the successful videos on our
Channel
they're all like these pre like they
take a lot of scripting and
Gathering of footage
getting everything just right you know
exactly
where it needs to be
Dustin with the 50. oh my gosh how about
now big enough yet
Dustin you are too kind my friend two
two kind
appreciate it dude
yeah it is tough Cloud Roth it is
like
but yeah it's like you have to find
you have to find either funny moments or
epic moments or like a good story moment
and then be able to
but I'll say I mean I showed you guys
like that that video that I took of the
this music I can't I just can't with
this
I need something a little bit more
okay this is better
oh Dustin I appreciate that dude
I appreciate that
that's the second 50 Super Chat from
Dustin tonight by the way
but yeah like if I could if I could
figure that out
but the video that I took from any time
I ever try to do it too man the videos
they bomb they don't do well
anytime I ever try to take something
from a live stream and turn it into a
video
it's like
maybe it's my style I have a totally
different
style like when I'm live streaming we're
it's it's hanging out man like my focus
is on you even my voice I think I talk
differently
when it's a pre-recorded video
and I don't know that I mean that
probably shows to viewers when people
are watching it's like they pick up on
the oh this is a highly highly produced
that might be the word for it it's like
people can tell when something's highly
produced and when it's like oh they just
pulled a clip from a stream and this is
their
this is their video right
so it's like my voice on a YouTube video
is more people of the internet retro
rack and tour here I'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
and in today's Hogwarts Legacy video I
have 10 insane bizarre never before seen
secrets that I'm gonna show you right
now starting with the fact that just
outside the rumor request
it's just like you know it flows totally
different
observe others who who are successful
follow the exam see that like Baxter
what's successful for me is not that
so
but yeah that's all part of the I love
it though man like I love trying to
figure it out
that's what I love so much about uh
about this whole content creation thing
basically script their YouTube video
just do it in the middle of stream Mia
that's a great point I have seen people
do that
I have seen people do that as well
yeah it's almost like I heard I've heard
some uh
creators describe it as if you can like
plan your stream
like if you can plan ahead to like okay
when we stream this I'm gonna be
setting up to make content around
kind of like what you said like you're
already planning what the video is going
to be so you may have a three hour
stream but within that three hour stream
you've got to do your
whatever your video is going to be you
got to get that
10 15 20 minute whatever it is in there
and I guess we've been doing that a
little bit with uh
not really because the Let's Plays I
mean that's just
I do a little bit of editing on those to
try to cut out any downtime if we stop
and chat for a long time during the live
stream I'll cut that out of the let's
play
GT live is that a
wait who's GT live
oh wow
oh Game Theory
oh yeah
I love this guy that's matpat right
that guy's a YouTube genius
a YouTube genius
oh I see here yeah so they do well
two weeks ago he did a live stream and
then
the most recent one before that was a
year ago
I wonder if he does any Twitch streaming
probably not he's probably only YouTube
Luke was workshopping Video Edit
steering his stream sure you could chat
with him about oh I noticed Luke's been
doing a little uh Twitch streaming as
well too lately
yes Nico that'd be a lot of fun we did
that a couple times back in the day I
don't know if you were there like
back before long before Hogwarts Legacy
we did uh
we did a couple Jack box things and they
were a lot of fun
yeah I feel like maybe like a once a
month Community night we need to uh
set that up
but then we'd have to figure out is it
on Twitch or is it on YouTube
because now I mean we've kind of settled
into a point now where I feel like
it's about the same viewership whether
we're on Twitch or YouTube
whereas you know in the lead up to
Hogwarts Legacy I wanted to keep
everything here
but now the viewer numbers I mean we'll
see how it goes in the future but it's
almost like
I probably need to pick up pick pick one
and stick with it
but I also want to do because we still
have so many people
joining over here as members
I want to make sure I'm doing something
worthwhile for people to have a reason
to be a member so if I stop doing the
live over here I think we would have to
do I would do like uh behind the scenes
weekly Vlog or something that's just a
more laid back
they do live recording more than actual
live streaming yeah a lot of the big a
lot of the big YouTube let's players
that's how they do it they it's more of
a pre-recorded thing so as you guys will
see on my let's play Channel
that channel man it's so funny because
like I just it's like I have zero stress
on that channel I don't have to worry
about I'm not worried about the views
over there I'm not worried about
subscriber numbers I mean I want to hit
a thousand so we can get partnered over
there
but it's like
I just trust that over time the people
that are interested in like those full
in-depth Let's Plays will will go over
and they'll subscribe and follow and it
will grow if it's if it's uh you know
meant to be if it's if it's stuff people
are interested in
because I had somebody comment they were
so worried they're like oh the views are
so much lower posting there and I was
like yeah I was expecting that though
you know
but what's crazy
what's crazy is like the analytics the
numbers that I I'm looking at I'm
already seeing better
so like our our most recent Hogwarts
Legacy let's play for example that was
posted on the let's play Channel
obviously does not have the views that
it got when we posted it on the main
Channel
but the click-through rate is higher
it's also getting shown to a lot less
people to be fair
but also the one that I'm really
interested in is the audience retention
so like how long people are watching
it's it's not it's not a lot longer but
it's a bit longer over there and so over
time hopefully that channel just becomes
you know anybody clicking on those
videos it's because they're interested
in watching a big a big lengthy in-depth
let's play
appreciate it JP watched all of them and
like thank you dude appreciate it
video breakdowns are also popular
yeah that yeah I mean that's what we do
I would say that's I would say that's
kind of our bread and butter Baxter when
we do the hidden details and facts and
all those things which stuff like that
like that's almost
that that has to be scripted that's
almost impossible to like pull from a
live stream you know
it's like
you can't I mean unless you scripted the
whole thing and just like hey guys I'm
gonna turn off alerts for a second and
I'm just gonna record all this
foreign
hey I appreciate it Timothy thank you
thank you
you always watch to the end and like oh
Baxter you're the best thank you
some Let's Play videos you can't watch
through is the camera swings make you
motion sick oh
with live I can watch the chat
interesting
retro reacts live I mean that's that's
sort of like what we did tonight wasn't
it we kind of just did reacting to
trailers and stuff
but yeah to go back to your question
Nico I love I love the idea I think I
didn't mean to go off on a tangent
but doing like a community night where
we posted in the uh
post it and like Build It Up in the
Discord
make sure we get it out on social media
all that that'd be fun we did some of
those on Twitch way back in the day and
they were always a good time
always a good time
see maybe a Seer I know right or like uh
Zelda you need to address this oh
there it is
all right guys this has been fun I hope
you all enjoyed this new format we'll
keep tweaking we'll keep working it out
figuring out you know
the structure and everything because I
it's also one of those things like doing
live
and having as much chat interaction as
we have
I don't want to do too much structure
because I wanna I wanna strike that
right balance of like okay we've got our
our topics that we want to discuss
but I I feel like we need to leave the
room leave room for me to have the the
back and forth with you guys
because if not then it's like
I might as well just do a pre-recorded
podcast you know
what's the point of making it live
hey good night Patrick we're about to
sign off as well
we are about to sign off as well Cloud
Roth good night thank you for being here
I'm gonna try to be live on uh twitch
tomorrow you guys probably with Star
Wars
so I would think around afternoon
around our usual 12 or one or one time
slot
but thank you all for being here man I
hope you guys enjoyed it I hope you
liked us uh checking out the trailers
and we'll see uh we'll see what we got
in store next week maybe there'll be
more trailers maybe it'll be uh
a lot more video game news to talk about
because we had quite a bit to discuss
this week
all right everybody uh have a great rest
of your week if you're not in the
Discord you can join that I think we
still have the
command for that set up here
Dustin Patrick elwin Nico
thank you guys all for the donations for
the gifteds very much appreciated
very much appreciated you guys are too
kind too kind
all right thank you all for being here
I don't know how to I don't know how to
end it for some reason
it's like
when we don't have the uh this this new
style it's throwing me off I feel like
I'm forgetting something what do we
forget to talk about
all right guys thank you all have a good
one
you were trying you were trying to drop
it don't lie you were trying to drop it
when I had already clicked away
when I had already clicked away I caught
you
Dustin thank you so much dude too kind
man
too kind always appreciated
all right you guys have a good one thank
you for being oh
I did see it in the chat I did see it in
the chat
see you later guys
you're a wizard Harry
Trey Buchanan thank you for the sub